[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 les
invités nous sommes le mardi 6 décembre
et une nouvelle fois la rédaction est
allé rencontrer celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité aujourd'hui vous entendrez
nathalie carrasco elle vient de recevoir
le prix irène joliot curie dans la
catégorie jeune femme scientifique c'est
ton seigneur et son enseignante pardon
chercheuse exerce au laboratoire
atmosphères milieux observations
spatiales le latmos de l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines et
puis interview également dans quelques
minutes d'omar sy le comédien était à
saint quentin en yvelines pour la sortie
de son nouveau film demain tout commence
une comédie dramatique dans laquelle il
partage l affiche avec une jeune actrice
talentueuse d'à peine 12 ans à nathalie
carrasco a donc reçu voici quelques
semaines le prix irène joliot curie dans
la catégorie jeune femme scientifique
une belle récompense pour cette
chercheuse engagé en faveur de l'égalité
hommes femmes
son travail porte sur l'atmosphère
supérieur de titan titan c'est le plus
gros satellite de saturne patrick
jacques de dixmude est allé la
rencontrer dans son laboratoire de
l'université yvelinoise donc ici vous
êtes dans dans ma salle de manip dans
laquelle on a développé toute une plate
forme d'expérience pour simuler la
chimie qui se déroule dans les
atmosphères des autres planètes du
système solaire
parmi tous les tous les objets du
système solaire qui sur lequel on peut
étudier la chimie des atmosphères y en a
un qui m'intéresse tout particulièrement
ces titans la plus grosse lune de
saturne
donc ça tue on a plein de lune
différentes mais il y en a une seule
titans qui a une atmosphère très épaisse
une atmosphère faite d'azoté et donc il
ne poster qui ressemble à celle de la
terre passé de la terre avant
l'émergence de la vie sinon qu'on
n'étudie titan pour étudier cette chimie
des origines de la vie sur la terre
primitive en thèse j'avais travaillé sur
la chimie de la terre aujourd'hui la
qualité de l'air et j'ai soutenu ma
thèse en 2000
5 et 2005 correspond à l'arrivée d'une
mission spatiale en orbite autour de
saturne qui est la mission
cassini-huygens et qu'ils allaient
explorer le système de saturne et en
particulier titans et donc c'est cette
mission qui a révélé une chimie
complètement inattendu une famille très
compliqué une chimie d origine et donc
c'est suite à ma task j'ai sauté sur
cette opportunité de travailler sur la
chimie de la chimie titan donc en 2005
la mission cassini-huygens est arrivé en
orbite autour de saturne mais elle avait
été lancée
beaucoup d'années avant elle avait été
lancée en 97 il a fallu sept ans de
trajet pour arriver jusqu'à jusqu'à
saturn et donc les premiers résultats
sont apparus et en fait ces résultats là
ils sont ils sont formidables mais ils
sont aussi assez compliqué et du coup
pour les interpréter les comprendre en
fait moi j'ai développé ici au
laboratoire des expériences qui vont
simuler titan est donc avec ces
expériences on va pouvoir simuler la
chimie on est bien loin encore de
l'émergence de la vie par contre quand
on regarde la vie de plus près c'est
c'est pas évident 1 personne ne sait
exactement comment la vie apparue par
contre quand on la regarde en détail on
sait qu'à l'échelle de la cellule elle
est toujours fait des mêmes matériaux
elle est toujours fait toujours fait la
vie de lipides de protéines
d'acides aminés et donc c'est sur ces
précurseurs chimiques là qu'on essaie de
voir comment la chimie des atmosphères a
pu participer à apporter ses briques de
la vie pour que voilà un moment donné la
vie s'en servent pour avoir voilà ces
matériaux de base pour construire la vie
telle qu'on la connaît aujourd'hui j'ai
reçu cette année le prix irène joliot
curie
en tant que jeune femme scientifique il
ya trois catégories donc moi il s'agit
de mettre en valeur cette cesser ses
travaux de recherche qui j'ai pu donc
avoir des résultats particulièrement
intéressant par rapport à cette
compréhension de la chimie des origines
depuis à ces dernières années mais
également mon engagement en faveur de
l'art et de la recherche des femmes suis
vraiment très très fier d'avoir reçu ce
prix en plus gelé reçu de la main de
madame hélène langevin-joliot donc la
fille irène joliot curie donc une grande
fierté mais également je suis très fier
parce pour le symbole que cela
représente
à savoir le fait que les femmes ont
toute leur place dans la recherche
scientifique que j'aime énormément c'est
les expériences vous voyez ici que j'ai
développé avec des collaborateurs avec
notamment des ingénieurs du laboratoire
on a pu à développer toute une
plateforme expérimentale est donc ce
sens de l'expérimentation de la
manipulation c'est ce goût là d'abord
qui m'a qui m'a emmené mais c'est
également l'observation
le fait d'avoir un objet compliqué dans
lequel il se passe plein de choses et
d'avoir voilà à développer plein
d'éléments pour essayer de comprendre ce
qui se passe dedans donc a aussi cet
aspect observations interprétation
analyse j'aime beaucoup et ce qui m'a
amené également à la recherche c'est la
notion de travail de laboratoire de
travail d'équipé nous changeons
d'univers à présent pour celui du 7e art
demain tout commencera à l'affiché
mercredi et dans cette comédie
dramatique
nous retrouvons l'yvelinois omar sy
comme souvent il a profité de son retour
de son exil à los angeles pour venir
présenter
il y tient toujours son film au public
de saint quentin en yvelines
elle me d'euros l'a rencontré à cette
occasion pour un moment dont lui aussi
se souviendra le comédien était
accompagné vous le verrez dans un
instant de la jeune révélation de ce
film c'est gloria cold stone elle n'a
que 12 ans nous sommes à l'ugc de 51
minutes pour l'avant première du film
j'ai recommencé
nous sommes à l'ugc de saint quentin en
yvelines pour l'avant première du film
demain à tout commence alors dans ce
long métrage qui sortira sur les écrans
donc ce mercredi à 7 décembre nous
aurons libinois omar sy qui a grandi à
quelques kilomètres de l'ugc de saint
quentin en yvelines
omar je me trompe pas oui c'est exact la
grappe mais si bien renseigné
voilà vous êtes bien renseigné du ciné
j'ai grandi à trappes à côté oui de
saint quentin en yvelines
voilà même si désormais vous vivez à los
angeles on l'a vu à quelques instants
pour l'avant première le public
trappistes qui suit avec attention
oui oui j'en reviens je reviens souvent
ici à skywest avec mes films est vrai
que j'ai la chance d'avoir des salles
toujours bien pleines avec un public qui
moser vins superbes accueille à chaque
fois et je suis très reconnaissant et
vous êtes également accompagné de gloria
gloria colston ces micro voilà bonsoir
bonsoir gloria ouais alors qu'est ce que
ça fait de jouer avec omar sy bah c'est
super voilà il est comme ça il est est
toujours drôle il fait toujours des
blagues et il m'a appris beaucoup de
choses parce que c'est mon premier film
mais qu'est ce qui t'a appris il m'a
appris
en fait parce qu'entre les scènes on
rigole beaucoup mais par contre quand on
travaille en fait il m'a appris à me
concentrer m'a pris à être sérieuses en
même temps que en même temps qu hugo et
antoine voilà le réalisateur de la
violence des pop corn en direct et
indirect
non c'est bon
alors votez complicité homard bleu rien
justement déconner si là parce qu'en
fait c'est toi qui es stressé
oui tu es stressé pourquoi qu'est ce
qu'il ya là ça c'est pas du direct non
c'est pas du direct tu vas monter c'est
ça c'est pas les débats avaient toutes
les fautes a bafouillé notre voilà
exactement une fois tu arrivais pas dire
skywest voilà rudi skywest cgc s'est
passé par fait mal à la gloria on en
parlait à l'elysée quelques instants les
commandes l'oréal et que l'oréal est
superbe elle est comme ça comme tu vois
là elle est très mignonne elle est une
bonne actrice
elle est très concentré elle apprend
très vite et les elle est très
surprenante mais des gens qui vont voir
le film dont le vent de comprendre très
vite
moi
[Musique]
on parlait de ce film omar depuis tout à
l'heure au feeling thériault ça pour le
film et allemand voilà le film justement
au niveau au niveau du scénario
en fait je fais ça j'ai un boulot comme
des cons et ça donne alors ce scénario
du coup il vous a plu tout de suite dès
que vous l'avez luc way très drôle tout
de suite tout de suite tout pour faire
tous les éléments pour une très bonne
comédie même temps les allemands pour
avoir un bon mélo un beau un bon moyen
de passer de l'un à l'autre comme ça et
après et après avec avec la mise en
scène de dugourd pour avoir le bon
équilibre entre les deux je crois que
c'était ça qu'il fallait heureusement
qu'on a vu hugo pour promettre 100
places et je crois qu'on a un film qui a
un bon équilibre de tout ça en fait d'un
film ou qui mêle à la fois le rire et
l'émotion un peu roller coaster on nous
a dit souvent donc j'aime bien c'est un
peu c'est ça ouais c'est un peu sa gle
en rien ces questions à gloria parce
qu'elle est cleveland des cleveland
puisque la vie écrivain les venues de
cleveland et tu pose pas de question et
surtout quand comme on est à dans les
yvelines
ça me gêne c'est qu'on lui avait réservé
un accueil digne de ce nom digne de ce
nom parce que sinon tu fout la honte
loria non ça va loria oui du coup ce
film à toi tu l'a ressenti comme ans du
début jusqu'à la fin thürler senti comme
en bas c'est un peu compliqué de le dire
comme ça on direct
voilà c'est ça non mais en fait au début
j'avais en fait hugo il m'a dit en gros
l'histoire j'ai vu le scénario
le scénario c'est ma plus au sénat
blouet sénat blu ray comprend tout il
serait aberrant tout est en fait qu il
me l'a dit après avoir lu le sénat blot
après voilà j'ai eu des émotions qu'ils
faut pas dire ça et là les gloriettes
alors une grande carrière selon vous
xala inch'allah mais voilà c'est son
premier film je trouve qu'elle démarre
très bien après il ya évidemment encore
des choses à apprendre encore des choses
à faire il y aura aussi des choix mais
en tout cas à la halle à tous tout ce
qu'il faut pour pour se lancer
je les encourage vivement même à
continuer mais ça je lui ai déjà dit et
mais voilà c'est c'est pas c'est passé
passait pas sans travail et sans ça sera
pas les doigts dans le nez mais comme je
sais que c'est déjà une grande bosseuse
je m'inquiète pas beaucoup après je suis
plutôt superstitieux donc je vais pas
envie non plus de trop dire parce que je
voudrais pas lui porter leur ai donc que
je remets 1,5 pour te protéger mon
enfant
dernière question mars il ya un film qui
va sortir à bientôt sur les écrans
star wars rogue one est ce que vous êtes
un fan de star wars tu te fous de ma
gueule tu es en train de te foutent de
ma gueule non valide
le film de demain tout comme ans qui
sera pas à l'affiché alléchante et le
film elle veut que je fasse la promo
pour star wars et non pas pour star wars
revient sans magie
j'ai un bébé sur les bras pour pas sa
mère j'ai tout perdu mon portefeuille
j'ai pu coucher une pleut pas nous
parlait français ça m'arrive vous allez
me sauver la vie avec plaisir on n'est
pas à peu près là c'est pas faux cils
changer d'avis il ya mes coordonnées pro
et ça c'est perso non je te parlerai pas
de star wars était malade star wars va
pas nous venir en même temps que nous à
la fiche je peux faire de la promo pour
star wars n'empêche pas pas poursuivre
le film qu'est ce que tu veux sans est
ce que ça pourrait vous intéresser un
jour donc déjà tourner l'épisode 9 1
l'épisode 9 bien sûr ça m'intéresse mais
même l'opa proposée ne proposeront pas
je pense c'est pas dans vos objectifs
vous connaissez très bien réalisateur
oui mais on ne fait pas ça se passe pas
comme ça tu sais c'est le réalisateur
qui choisit en fait on peut même si
c'est notre copain en appel peut me
donner un rôle j'ai vu je ferais pas ça
comme on va terminer à l'entretien là
dessus vous venez avis que cinq minutes
donc on va terminer là dessus voilà
alors demain tout commencera ce mercredi
7 décembre sur les écrans français
bravo tu abuses le téton c'était ton
baptême justin thomas
voilà pour le baptême de michael et demi
d'euros se souviendra de cette interview
rencontre avec omar sy c'est la fin du
set 8 invités pour ce soir prochaine
édition mercredi 18h45 nous ferons
notamment le point le bilan de l'édition
du téléthon sur le département des
yvelines avec le coordinateur
départemental est d'ici là n'oubliez pas
nous replay sur le site internet pour
revoir pourquoi pas cette interview
délicat difficile de marc simoneau
soirée
[Musique]